The problem with wanting to be friends
with your child is that that's not good
enough because as a parent,
you're not less than a friend.
You're far more than a friend.
You're someone that's going to be in the
child's life for the duration of your
life.
With any luck,
you're a longterm island of stability in
a sea of turbulence,
and the child needs that far more than
than he or she needs a friend.
Parents need to be courageous because
they have to let their children go and
make mistakes.
You have to let your child fall when
they're learning to walk.
They bump themselves up against the
world a lot,
and you don't want to do any more for
your child than you absolutely have to,
and it means that there's a certain
amount of detached harshness that has to
go along with your love and compassion.
You have to stand back and let your
child stumble forward towards mastery.
Today's parents are terrified of their
children because they're often afraid
that if they intervene in their lives,
that they'll make a mistake and that
that will be irrevocable.
And you have to have the courage of your
convictions when you have children.
And you have to understand that if you
do make mistakes,
that you can learn and you can be
forgiven.
You don't have to be a perfect parent,
although you should aim up with your
children.
Parents are terrified of making
mistakes,
and that means that they're terrified of
being parents and they,
and that stops them from being parents.